we're feeling okay smashing either side
is just not cool for me bashing that's
Khloe Kardashian in June talking about
the fallout from the Jordan woods and
Tristan Thompson cheating scandal but it
seems she felt a little different about
bashing sides a few months back and now
Khloe is in some hot water over fat
shaming Jordan and Tristan while taping
the finale of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians I know I was trying to
protect Khloe's heart yeah she doesn't
deserve this either
while on a girls trip to Palm Springs
with sisters Kim and Kourtney and her
bestie at Malika Haqq Coco called
Tristan's buddy back in Cleveland
after several margaritas Tristan you
could hear me and that's when we finally
got to see the moment fans have been
waiting all season for which included
the word fat social media was
immediately abuzz following Khloe's
comment one Twitter user wrote that The
Revenge body hosts true colors shined
after fat shaming the pair while another
asked can we understand Khloe Kardashian
for fat shaming Jordan woods you know
things happen and of course I'm sorry
and apologetic as much as I can be et
spoke with Jordan and Khloe separately
last month were they admitted it's time
to move on I personally don't watch it
back because I just I already know what
happens and it it's just I think a
little too toxic for me to keep reliving
stuff like that so I stay off social I
don't I didn't watch it and it's just a
part of our job that we
I have to do so we can't just pick and
choose what we want to show that's not
fair and so that's just what it is
everyone has the right to speak their
truth and hopefully everyone is just you
know going forward
[Music]